Theo cấu trạng các bị cáo lệ tấn linh giám đốc,
huyến thị thái hăng, hẳng dù mục, lệ thành công,
phạm quanh linh phóng linh vừa lốc vàng huyến thúc thuy tiền
có hậu và bình cũng tế hay in cùng trong phái mốt.
Mỹ truy tố vi còn bà xa sự thật về sản phẩm suất mơ gình
khai còn gọi là cạo kia ràng.
Cơ quan tụt cũng rất nhiều,
giám bị cáo vi só hàm lượng chất xơ trong cạo kia ràng rất thấp.
Chỉ không phải chính chăm mong là phần chăm một viên,
không có cần cụ khó hậu để khẩm đình,
một viên cạo bằng một dễ rau.
Dù vãi các bị cáo vẫn măn hành bằng tự tông bố
có hàm lượng xấu cố kia.
Sẽ vình kịch bàn và thực hiện nhiều video của mọi cáo,
với nội dung xan dù với thành phần,
tông dung vàng vồn gốc sản phẩm.
Từ nay, 12,5 năm,
hành công trong hàm tư diễn hệ mấy bố,
tầm bà, năm nay, hành công trong hàm lâm,
đã có hơn 5 yên khác hàng,
một một trong hàm bị chính yên khổ kèu,
tồng xanh thu hơn mấy bài phẩy năm tì đồng.
Trong đó, tù lợi bắt chính hơn mấy hài phẩy bốn tì đồng.
Fên toàn sẽ xem xếc giảm của tình bị cáo trong quá trình sản phất,
của mả và phần phối xen phần.